à l'écomusée de fougerolles au pays de
la cerise se racontent une autre
histoire
sur les murs les noms de 239 poilus des
enfants du pays qui ont sacrifié leur
vie aux champs de bataille en 14 18
alors pour leur rendre hommage
l'écomusée a fait appel aux habitants de
fougerolles pour collecter des documents
et objets de l'époque on a dû lire peut
être l'équivalent de 2000 lettres de
soldats et de leurs familles différentes
des objets qui nous ont permis de
reconstituer par exemple paquetage du
poids yeux quasiment complet un petit
peu d'armement on a vraiment constitué
un fonds très très impressionnant
la visite de l'exposition permet de
découvrir le quotidien de ces soldats
avec plus de 3000 objets de l'époque
j'ai porté donc un casque deux albums de
cartes postales et une douille gravé et
puis un livre ancien mon père
collectionner tous les tout ce qui avait
trait à la guerre oui ça faisait partie
ne dit pas du quotidien mais c'était on
entendait souvent parler on l'appelait
la der des ders ce chapitre de
l'histoire de france racontée à travers
les salles des comités de fougerolles un
cours d'histoire grandeur nature pour
les élèves des écoles de haute saône
là c'est une visite des ce2-cm1 de
fougerolles et se sont pratiquement 1500
scolaire depuis avril qu'ils ont
découvert cette exposition jarre tient
que sai qui vivent pas comme nous du
futur dans des conditions très
difficiles
dors même dans la terre ils étaient tous
mouillés
il pouvait pas se laver n'avait pas de
ta bille et ceux des outils en pierre et
avec des balles d'heure des munitions
c'est cette exposition a pu voir le jour
c'est sûrement grâce et une rencontre
celle de la directrice de l'écomusée
avec la nièce d'un soldats de 14-18
edmond cholet les voici edmond la voilà
voilà donc ça tu vas sainement sur les
quais mort en 1916 dans la salle
déchaînée à côté de l'écomusée denis
jeunet 85 ans a fait cadeau à l'écomusée
de la collection de cartes qu'écrivait
son oncle quand il était au front
des souvenirs qui lui rappelle sa grand
mère ma grand mère était illettrée et
naturellement bar lire le courrier de
son fils
qu'est ce que vous voulez salve est un
petit peu je vais dire quoi faire
adoucir la peine quoi parce que ça se
porte tout une vie ni saint côme est
donc je voulais qu'elle ne savait pas
lire
eh bien c'était moi qui étais chargé
mais faire la lecture grâce aux dons de
denise et nous et ses camarades sont à
l'honneur dans l'exposition à nos poilus
à découvrir jusqu'au 11 novembre à
l'écomusée de fougerolles